it's exciting tristan thompson might be
moving to boston
but don't expect to see khloe kardashian
packing up her things to join him
anytime soon i'm really just enjoying my
life
a source tells et that while coco is
thrilled for her beau's new gig playing
for the boston celtics
and she's fully supportive of this new
chapter in his career
she will not be moving to massachusetts
with him
chloe will not be uprooting her life to
move to boston but she'll be there often
and you'll definitely see her courtside
when covet is over
the source notes that the 29 year old
nba star will have a place in boston
that's big enough for his family to stay
in
adding that for chloe and tristan their
number one priority is their
two-year-old daughter
true it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that
chloe and tristan will continue to make
sure that both parents are majorly
involved and present in her life
i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
you share children with people and
that's how it should be
and love is love earlier this week
tristan's agent confirmed to yahoo
sports that he agreed to a deal with the
boston celtics
after nine seasons with the cleveland
cavaliers
the reported two-year contract is said
to be worth
19 million bucks hashtag oak
after the news broke the keeping up with
the kardashian star's brother rob
and sister kim both congratulated
tristan on social media
i love that of course tristan and chloe
rekindled their romance in august
after more than a year apart at the time
a source told et
the couple is back together and things
have been going really well
i'm just super happy and content the
athlete was
previously involved in multiple cheating
scandals
including one with kylie jenner's former
bestie
jordan woods you know things happen and
of course
i'm sorry and fans can watch the
couple's journey to reconciliation
as it's playing out on keeping up which
will return to e in 2021
for its 20th and final season i 100
have a block up but who wouldn't like
every relationship i go into they're
always
disappointing and dumb so i have every
reason
to be guarded i have every reason to
have these
bricks up in layers and if somebody
cares enough
they will take those bricks down brick
by brick
you